Well, here we are, nearly
the end of Google I/O 2015,
and it's been a great show.
I'm a game designer, and
I've been focusing on games.
And one of the things that
I love about this show
is that we go all the way back
to the early '80s and the game
here "Joust" that I was actually
a tester on in 1982, all
the way up to modern day when
these games are still fun,
but the new technologies and a
lot of the stuff we're showing
here at I/O is getting
used in current games
and future games that may
even be of types and genres we
haven't seen yet.
It's been very
inspiring here for me.
I've been able to be a part
of the audience at some
of our talks and see some
of the great new things
we have coming out.
I'm particularly excited by how
Google's at the forefront of VR
at this point.
The Cardboard team
has announced that we
have over a million Cardboards
in the hands of people
worldwide and having such an
inexpensive and accessible way
for people, for small developers
to get into virtual reality.
And for the audience that
we're after, for people
around the world,
for just $20 or less
to be able to get
a Cardboard device
and plug their phone in
and see the kind of quality
VR that it's able to do.
I think is going to be
amazing to see what's
coming out in the next year.
Meanwhile, we have things
like our Project Tango
that is giving devices a
human-scale understanding
of their surroundings.
It's going to be able to
transform GamePlay and give us
new types of games we
haven't seen before.
And the ATAP group has been
announcing new technologies
that allow different types of
control for games or anything
that I think is just going to
be revolutionary for the kinds
of applications and
games we can see.
And one of the reasons
that I love games
is that if you're trying to do
business software, for example,
and you have something
that works about 90%
of the time and 10%
it gets almost there,
it's nowhere near
acceptable for business.
But if it's 90% of the
time working in a game,
and it's fun, and
even when it fails
it's still something
that's enjoyable,
several of the features in
this game "Joust" over here
were actually bugs.
They were so much
fun they decided
to leave them in because
it enhanced the game.
And there's a
flexibility in games
that I think a lot of the new
technologies we're seeing here
today will get pioneered in
games and will get polished
and honed so they could be used
in other types of applications
around the world after we've
had a chance to see what's
fun with them.
So it's been a long
I/O. A lot of people
are excited and happy, but a
little bit tired at the end.
And I think we're all happy
to be doing something that
can make a difference
to the world
and also make people a little
bit happier and entertain them.
Because what's better
than having a good time
at the end of the day?
Thanks and have a good
time at home, too.
[MUSIC PLAYING]